Betty White she should die soon right oh
you're with me and an ass full of Betty
White
yeah you've had an [ __ ] ever right
look I get it I know her careers had a
resurgence and she's a national treasure
whatever but [ __ ] enough with the
Betty White Betty White
no you wouldn't oh yeah let me into that
funny
you know that kind of [ __ ] she would
know to bring to the table and whatnot
you dispensary Betty Betty white would
[ __ ] you out of this world [ __ ] you and
Betty white across from each other in
tables like that scene in Raiders of the
Lost Ark and she's Karen Allen as Marion
Ravenwood you the big [ __ ] Apollo guy
that's like oh because Betty White's
like [ __ ] you know how much [ __ ]
I've done get over here give it a go
Garmin she just hold your head like this
why should we run to the Golden Girls
but what happens when I enter her and
snap her pelvis
when osteoporosis rears its ugly head
and her bones turned to dust with my
powerful man thrust she's got to worry
about is your low-hanging balls exactly
slipping between her legs and crashing
her in the back of the head
[Music]
but cussing that poor woman I would
break her in half
I would [ __ ] her to dust is what would
happen you're like a [ __ ] lost art
it's right Italy she'd be like a mummy
she was like a Betty White shaped cloud
after I've her I was inside of her looks
like she ran in the cartoon she's
[ __ ] 90 enough already with Betty
White
she brings the funny man funny will turn
me on even for a woman at that age it's
like she's clever well you may change
your mind this week because she's just
released her first rap song yeah see now
you're on my side she's got a new rap
song that she did with a British
singer-songwriter named Luciana
and apparently Luciana had a hit with a
song called I'm still hot and so she and
Betty White have done a remix where it's
a duet where Betty White talks about how
she's still hot okay and I think I don't
know hot flashes count but the lyrics
something like I may be senior but so
what I'm still hot I left my Emmys in my
beatbox that what she calls her badge
where she puts her bacon that trophy is
awfully cruel looking I will get you
sweaty because I'm big Betty she writes
I brought it a little taste of the audio
of Betty White singing her new rap song
okay and after you hear this I'm sure
like I you will be looking forward to
next week's Tinseltown sniffs in the
hope will be joining Andy Rooney in our
bigs here's a little piece of Betty
White
[Music]
no you're not Betty oh I'm sorry you get
the booby prize they're not here to
cause no trouble she's just here to do
the Super Bowl fits very much
[Music]
you
[Music]